[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاده الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وهذا المشهد في المدينه
التي تعيش على واقعي مواجهات مستمره
وانفجارات في محيط التصر الرئاسه
رام الله والمشهد مع استمرار التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه الاحتلال
يغتال شابين فلسطينيين في طولكرم
لندن تعيش ايضا اجواء تاريخيه مع تتويج
تشارلز الثالث الملكه الاربعين للعرش
البريطاني في تقاليده وطقوس تعود لاكثر من
الف عام
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
لاول مره منذ بدء الازمه محادثات في مدينه
جده السعوديه بين الطرف النزاع في السودان
ومتحدث باسم الجيش يقول للجزيره ان
المناقشات تركز على الهدنه ولن تبحث
اتفاقا نهائيا لوقف اطلاق النار ميدانيا
معارك ضاريه حول مواقع استراتيجيه ومقر
عسكريه بالخرطوم
في تصعيد جديد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يغتال
شابين فلسطينيين في طولكرم بضفه الغربيه
وحماس الشاهدين وتؤكد انتمائهما لكتائب
القسام وفصائل فلسطينيه تدعو الى التصعيد
بعد انتقادات لرئاسه الاركان الروسيه بسبب
ما اعتبره نقصا في الذخيره رئيس فاجنر
يطلب من موسكو تسليم مواقع مجموعته في
بخموت لقوات قاديروف الشيشانيه واوكرانيا
تقول ان منظومه الامريكيه اسقطت صاروخ
الروسيا فرط صوتي من تراس كينجال روسيا
تقول انها اسقطت صاروخين بالسين اوكرانيين
فوق شبه جزيره القرم
وفي احتفال يمزج بين التاريخ والحداثه
تتويج تشارلز الثالث على عرش المملكه
المتحده في اكبر حدث من نوعه في بريطانيا
منذ سبعه عقود بحضور قاده وشخصيات من
انحاء العالم
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد ضع على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الجديد في الضفه الغربيه
باغتيال الشابين الفلسطينيين حمزه خريوش
وسامر الشافعي خلال اقتحام مخيم نور شمس
في طولكرم هذه المره والاستطاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما هو المسار المتوقع بعد
اغتيال الاحتلال شابين فلسطينيين في
طولكرم النتائج جاءت على النحو التالي
42% توقعوا مزيدا من التصعيد الاسرائيلي
ضد الفلسطيني
53% اعتبروا ان التصعيد الاسرائيلي سيؤدي
الى مواجهات المتبادله وعلى نطاق واسع اما
التدخل الدولي والخارجي لوقف التصعيد
الاسرائيلي فقد صوت لذلك فقط 5% من
المشاركين في التصويت
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسخره الظاهر الان على الشاشه
ولقائنا يتجدد في المنصات الرقميه يوميه
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
اكثر من 50 قتيلا في اشتباكات قبليه شمال
شرقي الهند والسلطات تدفع بتعزيزات امنيه
وتنقل نحو عشرين الفا الى مخيمات لوقف
التصعيد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بالتزامن مع التطورات الميدانيه
في السودان اكد طرف النزاع في هذا في
السودان مشاركتهما في محادثات تعقد في
مدينه جده السعوديه هي الاولى منذ اندلاع
الازمه السودانيه وبينما رحبت الرياض
وواشنطن بتلك المحادثات الاوليه واعربت عن
الامل في ان تؤديه الى انهاء النزاع قال
متحدث باسم الجيش السوداني للجزيره ان
التفاوض يبحث اليات تمديد الهدنه ولا يشمل
قضايا سياسيه
هي اللغه ذاتها
كالا صدى هنا لاحاديث السلام بين اشتباكات
وقصف وانفجارات توزعت ساعات يوم جديد من
عمر محنه السودان
تلك يوميات السودانيين الموعودين بواحده
اخرى من هدن المتحاربين الهشه
تتوقع دوائر استخباراتيه غربيه معارك
طويله الامد في السودان لان الطرفين كما
تقول يعتقدان ان بامكان كل منهما الانتصار
عسكريا وانه ليست لديهما دوافع تذكر
للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
نحو ذلك التفاوض تدفع جهود مجموعه دول
الرباعيه وجامعه الدول العربيه والاليه
الثلاثيه لذلك فهي تبارك الحراك الامريكيه
السعوديه الذي اثمر قبلا عن هدن تبادل
المتحاربون في السودان الاتهامات بخرقها
والان تنبثق عن تنسيق الرياض واشنطن
محادثات اوليه هي الاولى من نوعها تجمع
ممثلي كل من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
يقول وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان بلاده تامل ان يقود حوار
الطرفين الى انهاء الصراع وانطلاق العمليه
السياسيه في السودان
ويضيف الوزير السعودي ان استضافه
المباحثات السودانيه هي نتاج تكاتف دولي
وجهود حديثه مع الولايات المتحده وبشراكه
مع دول المجموعه الرباعيه والاليه
الثلاثيه
البيان السعودي الامريكي المشترك بشان بدء
المحادثات السودانيه كان قد حث الطرفين
على الاخذ في الاعتبار مصالح الامه
السودانيه وشعبها والمشاركه بنشاط في
المحادثات نحو وقف اطلاق النار وانهاء
الصراع كما دعا الى مواصله تنسيق الدعم
الدولي لعمليه التفاوض الموسعه والتي قال
انه يجب ان تشمل جميع الاحزاب السودانيه
والى ضروره ضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
قوات الدعم السريع رحبت بالبيان واكد
قائدها محمد حمدان حميدتي في تغريده على
تويتر ما قال انه موقفه الثابت بضروره
الوصول الى حكومه انتقاليه مدنيه تؤسس
لتحول ديمقراطي كما اشاد حميدتي بالجهود
الاقليميه والدوليه المبذوله للوصول الى
وقف اطلاق نار يسهل فتح ممرات انسانيه
يتفاعل الجيش السوداني هو الاخر بايجابيه
مع محادثات جده لكن ناطقا باسمه قال
للجزيره ان تفاوض سيشمل قضايا عسكريه
وانسانيه ولا علاقه له باي قضايا سياسيه
نحن اعلنا عند انطلاق وفدنا او مغادره
وفدنا الى جده ان هذا الوقت ذهب
وسيناقش الجوارب التي تتعلق بالهدنه بما
يتم تنفيذها لتحقيق او لخدمه الاغراض
الانسانيه بالمقام الاول وان يكن فالقوه
المدنيه الواقعه على الاتفاق الاطاري في
السودان تامل في ان تقود المباحثات الى
وقف القتال ومعالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه بما
يمهد لحل سلمي سياسي مستدام بيان تلك
القوه حث القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
على اتخاذ ما دعاها قرارات شجاعه تنتصر
لصوت الحكمه
هذا واكد الاتحاد الافريقيه انه يتابعه عن
كثب المحادثات التي بدات في جده بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع وحث الاتحاد والاطراف في بيان الله
على الاتفاق بشان وقفه اطلاق النار لاسباب
الانسانيه على وجه السرعه كخطوه اولى
للسماح بالامداد الفوري بمواد الاغاثه
لتخفيف معاناه المدنيين السودانيين ودعا
للموافقه على الفور على فتح ممرات انسانيه
لتسهيل توزيع الامدادات الاساسيه واستعاده
الخدمات
معنى من جده مراسله الجزيره بدر ربيعان
بدر اهلا بك اذا بدات هذه المحادثات في
برعايه الخارجيه السعوديه وفق المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه هل هناك اي معلومات عن
ما تمت مناقشته حتى الان من يشارك عدد
الوفود المشاركه او الممثلين لكل الطرف
نعم زين حتى الان لم يصدر اي بيانات من
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه بخصوص العمليه
التفاوضيه التي انطلقت ظهر اليوم هنا في
جده الترشيحات الاوليه سوف يستكمل طرفي
النزاع قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات التدخل
السريع جوله ثانيه من المفاوضات يوم غد
اذا ما تحدثنا عن راعي المفاوضات وهما
السعوديه وامريكا سوف يدخلون بالتاكيد في
مرحله تقديم اقتراحات وحلول خلال الايام
المقبله بشكل اكبر من اليوم بحكم الجلوس
مع الطرفين والسماع لما يقدمونهم معلومات
وغنود تفاوضيه فريق المفاوضات المتواجدون
في جده لكل الطرفين يصل الى سبعه اشخاص
حقيقه لا توجد معلومات عن تفاصيل
المفاوضات التي تجري سوى ما سيصدر من
بيانات رسميه وما صدر من الجانب السعودي
وممثلا بوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه بالتاكيد
المفاوضات ستبحث ما يتعلق بتمديد الهدنه
مدى التزام الطرفين بها اضافه الى توفير
ممرات انسانيه امنه لوصول المساعدات
للمناطق المتضرره وبوجود فريق تفاوض من كل
من كل طرف هناك من يتحدث انه سيعطي فرصه
اكبر لتنديد الهدنه الحاليه وهذا بحد ذاته
يعتبر نقطه ايجابيه لهذه المفاوضات
تجري في وقت يتقاتل في الطرفان على ارض
السودان جاءت نتيجه لجهود دبلوماسي سعودي
امريكي بهدف جمع طرف
مفاوضات واحده والوصول للتوافق مبدا وايضا
وضع خطه الطريق للخروج من هذه الازمه على
كافه الاصعده الانسانيه والعسكريه
والسياسيه اضافه الى وقف العمليات
العسكريه والتاكيد على انهاء الصراع هذه
المبادره لقي الترحيب الدوليه الترحيب من
اطراف النزاع المتواجدين هنا يعني الجانب
السعودي والامريكي نادى بها منذ ان اشتعلت
هذه الازمه نتحدث عن جهد دبلوماسي سعودي
سواء في مسار المفاوضات وحتى في مسار
عمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم بها الحكومه
السعوديه عبر اسطولها البحري حيث يتواجد
ايضا خليه دبلوماسيه تابعه لوزاره
الخارجيه في بورت سودان تدري عمليات
الاجلاء من هناك الى بناء جده البارحه كان
هناك اتصال بين وزير الخارجيه السعودي
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ووزير الخارجيه
الامريكيان توني بلينكن اكد فيه على اهميه
التصعيد العسكري وبين الاطراف المتنازعه
وانهاء اعمال العنف الجاريه في السودان
اليوم ايضا صدر بيان سعودي امريكي حث
اطراف النزاع على استشعار المسؤوليه تجاه
الشعب السوداني والخراط بجديه في هذه
العمليه التفاوضيه والمباحثات ورسم خارطه
الطريق خلال المرحله المقبله الازمه
السودانيه حقيقه جاءت في وقت عملت في
السعوديه خلال الفتره الماضيه بسياسه
تصفير الازمات ونقاط الاشتباكات اشتباك
تماثل معها نتحدث عن ملف ايران اليمن
سوريا واذا ما تحدثنا تحدثنا عن السعوديه
فهي معنيه بشكل مباشر بالتعاطي مع هذه
الازمه بحكم الموقع الجغرافي والثقل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك بدر ربيعان مراسله
الجزيره من جده وينضم الينا في الاستوديو
سامع عيدروس محلل الشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه السودانيه استاذ اسامه اهلا بك
هذا اول اول محادثات بين الطرفين
الوفد الممثل لكل طرف سبعه من الشخصيات
تعقد في جده حتى الان بيانات لا معلومات
لكن من الشكل ماذا يدل على ما يدل هذا
الشكل سبعه من هذا الجانب وسبعه من هذا
الجانب في مكان الواحد في مبنى وزاره
الخارجيه
اذا نظرنا الى الامن الوطني للدوله
السودانيه
فتوصيف الصراع واضح جدا وبالتالي هذه
المفاوضات واضحه ايضا هذا صراع عسكري يا
يدور بين الجيش من جانب وقوه عسكريه بين
التوصيف انا اريد ان اعرف فيما يتعلق
بالمفاوضات يعني هذه توصيف يعني التوصيف
ليس عليه اجماع لا انا لا اريد لا في داخل
لا اريد لا اريد ان اوصف وصفا سياسيا ولا
ولا اتكلم عن الاطراف انا اتكلم عن دوله
سودانيه حصل فيها
مسلحتين وانا اتحدث عن محادثتين سبعه من
هذا الجانب وسبعه من هذا الجانب نعم هذا
الشكل على ما يدل يدل على انه هذه مفاوضات
عسكريه مفاوضات على مجريات ترتيبات امنيه
بين قوتين عسكريين هذه الرساله التي اريد
ان اوصلها لك انه هذه المحادثات هي
محادثات عسكريه واضحه تتحدث عن يعني
الحرب نفسها وتوصيفها في القانون الدولي
الانساني واضح انه اثناء الحرب لا يجوز
ضرب الاعيان المدنيه
واذا يعني دخلت الجيوش الى الاعيان
المدنيه يمثل هذا الجريمه حرب وجريمه
انسانيه
فشل الهدنات السابقه في انها لم يعني لم
يحدد الطرفين اي شيء يعني كانت اعلان عن
هدنه مفتوحه بدون تفاصيل بدون اي اجراءات
فالان بعد التدخل الاطراف الخارجيه
ودعوتها لهذه الهدنه والسعوديه يعني دوله
مقبوله لدى الطرفين ولها تعامل
جدا مع الطرفين ولها يعني خبره سابقه في
اداره نزاعات مسلحه داخل دول عربيه
واسلاميه كمقبوله للطرفين وبقيه الوساطه
الذين يتدخلون خصوصا
الضغط الافريقي الكبير الذي ينطلق من
الدوله يعني ينطلق من الدوله والتاكيد على
حق الدوله في سيادتها في اراضيها وغير ذلك
من هذه الاشياء لذلك توصيف الصراع الان
انه صراع على
ترتيبات امنيه عسكريه نسبه لخروقات حصلت
اثناء الهدنه خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالجانب
الانساني الذي ضيق على حياه الناس
ومهاجمه الاعيان المدنيه بحصف توصيف
القانون الدولي الانساني واهمها
المستشفيات والمرافق الخدميه وغيرها هل
يمكن ان يكون هذا العدد من الممثلين لكل
من البرهان واحمدتي في هذه فقط لترتيب
الممرات الانسانيه
انه يعني يمكن البناء عليه
اتفاقات سياسيه مع اظن العوده مره اخرى
الى
المسار الذي كان قبل بدء هذه المواجهات
بالضبط يعني انا اريد ان افصل بين المسار
السياسي للازمه
والمساره العسكري للازمه هذه المفاوضات
مختصه بالمسار السياسي فقط
المسار العسكري فقط للازمه
والتوصيف الوفدين بانه وفد برهان ووفد
يعني لا يجوز في هذه الحاله لانه الوفد
الذي ذهب من الجيش في اكثر من ممثلين خارج
القوات المسلحه نفسها كانه يريد ان يصف
نفسه بانه وفدي للدوله السودانيه بينما
الجانب الاخر طبعا هو وفد من الدعم السريع
مكون من سبعه افراد الجانب السياسي لا
يمكن حله في خلال مفاوضات عسكريه وفي
هنالك غياب تام من الجانب السياسي
ويحتاج الى قيادات مسؤوله على الارض تظهر
كقيادات للدوله السودانيه الجانب العسكري
يقوده العسكريون الجانب السياسي مفترض ان
يقوده السياسيون وهم غائبون في هذه اللحظه
لم تسهر قيادات حقيقيه تدير الازمه
السياسيه الدوله السودانيه نفسها لم يكن
فيها يعني الموجوده كان شبهي حكومه لمده
عامين لذلك ليس هنالك اي اداره مدنيه
لشؤون الحرب وظهرت هذه الاشكالات
الانسانيه
قياده حكيمه سياسيه تخرج من
محاوله تسجيل اهداف سياسيه من خلال هذه
في منتهى الاهميه وقد اثرناها في الجزيره
السابقا وهو لا يوجد وجه مدني
لكل لهذا الصراع على الاطلاق لانه
صوت المعارك فقط هو الذي يسمع لكن نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا
السياسيه والعسكريه
في التطورات الميدانيه دخلت المواجهات بين
الجيش والقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها
الرابع في العاصمه حلقت الطائرات الحربيه
في اجزاء واسعه من وسط الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري كما دوت انفجارات عنيفه
في محيط القصر الرئاسي حي الوابورات
بالخرطوم بينما سمعت اصوات واسلحه ثقيله
صباح اليوم تزامنا مع تصاعدي اعمله الدخان
في مواقع مختلفه جنوب الخرطوم بحري في
جنوب مدينه اللبيض ادت الاشتباكات بين قوه
عسكريه تابعه للدعم السريع واحدى المكونات
الاجتماعيه الى مقتل ثمانيه اشخاص وجرح
اخرين واشارت مصادر للجزيره ان اسباب
الاقتتال ذات طابع قبلي اخيرا قدرت نقابه
اطباء السودان عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات
المدنيين ب 479 قتيله واكثر من
2500 جريح
وللقوفه على اخر تطورات الميدانيه ينضم
الينا من جنوب الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي ومعنا عبر الهاتف من
الخرطوم بحري مراسل الجزيره احمد فضل
وابدا بالطاهر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم
الطاهر
نعم في جنوب الخرطوم هنالك هدوء حذر في
هذه اللحظات لا نسمع
انفجارات او اي نوع من الاشتباكات
المباشره العسكريه الا من اصوات بعض
الطلقات الرصاص التي لا تدل على ان هنالك
مواجهات او اي نوع من الاشتباكات عكس ما
كان في الصباح الباكر او عند
ساعات متاخره كان هنالك بعض الاصوات التي
كنا نسمعها من حين الى اخر والتحليق
للطائرات ولكن الان هنالك هدوء حدد في هذه
المنطقه والكل الان والانظارتديه نحو
مدينه جده حيث المفاوضات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع والبعض يعتقد
انها ربما تكون هي بدايه المخرج لهذه
الازمه باتفاق النهائي ينهي هذه الحرب
خاصه وان الاوضاع الانسانيه اصبحت متفقمه
والكل الان يتطلع لانهاء هذه الظروف
الاستثنائيه التي يمر بها السودان خوفا من
تشعب هذه الحرب واتزاع هذه الدائره اذا
كانت الامور تسير بهذه الطريقه على الرغم
من ان الحديث بان مفاوضات مدينه جده ربما
تتناول فقط الهدنه والاعمال الانسانيه لكن
البعض يعتقد انها ممكن ان تكون مدخل حقيقي
لانهاء هذه الازمه هنالك مناشدات ايضا من
القوه السياسيه وبعض منظمات المجتمع
المدني وكذلك بعض الاصوات التي استمعنا
اليها في الراي العام في بعض المناطق التي
تجولنا فيها انهم يريدون وقت لاطلاق النار
لان الاوضاع الانسانيه في دخولها الاسبوع
الرابع بدت الكثير من السلعه التي ترتفع
في الاسعار وتقل تدريجيا هناك سلعه ضروريه
غير يعني
مثلا شحال الوقود واغلاق طلمبات الوقود
بات ملحوضا ويسعوا يعني حضور اي نوع او
احضار اي نوع من الامداد
البترولي في هذه المناطق بالاضافه سيوله
النقديه توقف المصارف ايضا يؤثر بشكل
مباشر على المواطنين لاحظنا ذلك ايضا على
حركه المواطنين في الشوال بدات تتراجع
لدرجه ما وهم يطالبون بان هذه الظروف يجب
ان يعني قبل ان يفوت قبل فوات الاوان لابد
من الاتفاق على
وقت دائم تحدثت عن الهدوء الطاهر المرضي
هل هل هل كانت هنالك اي اشتباكات اثناء
هذه المحادثات التي جرت في السعوديه ام ان
هذه المحادثات تزامنت مع سكوت لاصوات
الانفجارات والمدافع
بشكل عام
لا لا اعتقد ان هذه المفاوضات التي بدات
في السعوديه لها علاقه باي نوع من الهدوء
وهي هدنه
كسابقاتها تتخللها الخروقات تتخللها
التبادل يتقلى تبادل الاتهامات بين
الطرفين لان مثل هذه المدن التي تعلم من
حين للاخر هي كانت استجابه لدعوات سواء
كان من الاتحاد الافريقي او من السعوديه
والولايات المتحده ولكنها هدى هشه تنهار
في اي لحظه خاصه وان الجيش واقوات الدعم
السريع على انها في وقت بدايه هذه الهدن
بانه هذا لا يلغي حق الرد وبالتالي يتم
خرق هذه الهدن بشكل او باخر دون ان تكون
هنالك اليات مراقبه حقيقيه فان مثل هذه
الهدى لم تكن متماسكه شكرا جزيلا لك
الطائر المرضي مراسله من الجنوب الخرطوم
ونت
حول الى الخرطوم بحري ومراسل الجزيره احمد
فضل ليطلعن ايضا على كيف تعيش هذه المنطقه
من الخرطوم الان وفي خلال الساعات الماضيه
وهي التي تعيش منذ بدايه المواجهات على
وقع اشتباكات وقصف مستمر احمد
نعمل الخرطوم بحري شان عشان الخرطوم حذر
مقارنه
الماضيه سوى من طلقات الرصاص
ومدفعيه المضادات المضادات الطيران تطلق
من حين الى اخر حيث ان الطيران الحربي
يتخذها مسارا وهو يتجه صوب الخرطوم عبر
الطريقه الخرطوم بحريه وتبدا مضادات
الطيران التابعه للدعم السلاحي التعامل مع
الطيران الحربي من من هذه المنطقه
ايضا من الملاحظه ان قوات الجيش السوداني
عززت قواتها الموجوده في الشمال الخرطوم
بحري عندها منطقه جسر الحلفائي الذي يربط
شمال الخرطوم بحري بمدينه ام درمان هذه
القوات بدات تتزايد منذ الامس
ارسال من السيارات التابعه للدفاع
لقوات الجيش حضرت منهم جرماني
وخيمت في تلك المنطقه الشمال عند منطقه
الحلفايه على مستوى على المستوى الانساني
ما زال مستشفى نداءات لمده بالمستهلكه
حيث ان مدير قبل المستوى الانساني احمد
فضل هذه القوات التي تقول انها عزه وجودها
قوات الجيش التي عزت وجودها عند جسر
الحلفايه قدمت من ام درمان هل هل هنالك
قوات جاءت من خارج الخرطوم ام مازلنا
نتحدث عن تحرك لقوات داخل الخرطوم
بمدنيه الثلاث طبعا لا هذا هذه هذه
التحركات بحسب هي داخل الخرطوم قوات من
عبره الى الخرطوم بحريه من ام درمان التي
تقع قرب غرب الخرطوم
بحري
هناك معلومات تشير الى ايضا الى وجود قوه
من نهر النيل ربما هي في الطريق الى ام
درمان ربما تعبر بعض سالك الى الخرطوم حسب
المعطيات
لكن
القوات الملاحظه انها عززت وعززت قوه
الجيش عزت قواتي في تلك المنطقه منذ الامس
وحتى اليوم بشكل واضح ولكن للانظر شكرا لك
احمد فضل مراسله من الخرطوم بحري
وصلت الى مطار بورسودان الدولي طائره
جديده تحمل شحنه جديده من المساعدات
الانسانيه التي تقدمها هيئات وجمعيات
خيريه قطريه وقال محمد صلاح مدير قطاع
الاغاثه والتنميه الدوليه بالهلال الاحمر
القطري ان المساعدات التي وصلت الى مطار
بورت سودان اليوم تقدر بنحو 22 طن من
المواد الطبيه والاحتياجات الخاصه
بالاسعافات الاوليه وسيتم توزيعها على
المتضررين من القتال في السودان
[موسيقى]
ارني الحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ونبداها
بتطورات الميدانيه وتحديدا باعلان حاله
التاهب الجوي في كييف ومناطق شرقي وجنوب
اوكرانيا وينضم الينا من كيف مراسل
الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان اذا تحديث جديد
اعلان حاله الطوارئ
والتاهب تحسبا لماذا
نعم ما زين بعد رصد انطلاق سفارات الانذار
هنا في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف كما في
عدد من المدن والمقاطعات شرقيه وجنوبيه
اوكرانيا
تم رصد انطلاق طائرات تسمى بالقاذفات
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه من عدد من المواقع
حتى هذه اللحظه يجري الحديث في الاعلام
المحلي عن رصد اربع طائرات او قاذفات
استراتيجيه روسيه تحلق في الاجواء وتتخذ
مواقع قريبه من خطوط اطلاق الصواريخ ولهذا
جرى التنبيه واعلان حاله التاهب الجوي في
هذه المناطق حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم رصد
اطلاق للصواريخ في اتجاهات محدده في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه او باتجاه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الا ان الادارات العسكريه
المحليه تحذر المواطنين من ضروره
الاستجابه لسفارات الانذار والاحتماء في
اماكن امنه الى حين انتهاء حاله الانذار
الجوي هذه الحاله تاتي في ظل محاولات خلال
الايام الماضيه
لضرب العاصمه الاوكرانيه وعدد من المناطق
سواء كان عبر المسيرات الانتحاريه او عبر
الصواريخ الباليستيه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى وياتي في ظل قيام
دفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه باسقاط
الاجسام الطائره التي تنطلق باتجاه
مدن والمناطق الاوكرانيه بما فيها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه واخر المعلومات كانت
افصحت عنه قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
عندما اعلنت اليوم انها وفي يوم الرابع من
مايو وتحديدا خلال ليله الرابع من مايو
قامت اسقاط صاروخ من طراز كنجال
74 هذا الصاروخ هو صاروخ فرد صوتي تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت باربعه اضعاف تم اسقاطه
في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه
بواسطه منظومه
الدفاعات الجويه
الامريكيه التي كانت قد سلمتها اوكرانيا
من المانيا قبل اسبوعين ويعتبر هذا الحدث
هو الحدث الاول من نوعه منذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كانت قد افصحت عنه
قياده القوات الجويه بعد يومين من التكتم
على هذه المعلومه وبعد تداول هذه المعلومه
عبر مواقع عسكريه وايضا الاداره العسكريه
لمنطقه كييف هذا يشير الى التاهب الكبير
للدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه على مستوى
البلاد تحسما من اي ردود فعل روسيه على
اتهام روسيا لاوكرانيا
باستهداف قاصر او مبنى الكرملين في الرابع
او الثالث من مايو الجاري وقد وربما سنبحث
لاحقا ايضا في الحصاد ان كان يشير الى
تطور كبير في القدرات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه
شكرا لك حسن مسعود منك
وجه مؤسس شركه فاغنري
طلبا رسميا لوزير الدفاع الروسي السير جاي
شويغو لاصدار امر عسكريا بتسليم المناطق
التي تخضع لسيطره قوته في باخموت للقوات
الشيشانيه وكان بريجوجن قد اكد استمرار
التقدم قوته في مدينه باخموت رغم نقص
الذخيره وفي تطور عسكري لافت ايضا اعلن
قائد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه الفريق
نيكولاي اولي شوك اسقاط صاروخ روسي من
طراز كنجال فرط الصوتي في سماء كيف خلاله
هجوم الليليه تعرضت له المدينه الخميس
الماضي وصف اولي شوك اسقاط الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه الصاروخ الروسيه لاول مره بانه
حدث تاريخي
يتواصل القتال على جبهات عديده في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا في بخموت معارك في
الذروه وزخم متعدد الاوجه
رئيس الشركه فاجنر الذي هاجم بضراوه مؤخرا
قيادات الجيش في موسكو واتهمهم بخذلان
قواته يكرر الشكوى من نقص الذخيره معلنا
انه سيترك وراءه وحدات عسكريه شيشانيه
فيما وصفها
العدو يسحب باتجاه بخموت يوميا ما بين 400
الى 600 عسكريين وهذا هو عدده الخسائر
اليوميه من القوات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
تقريبا العدو لا يدخر الذخائر وقد ظهر
لديه ما يكفي من المدرعات الاجنبيه واعداد
كبيره من المسيرات انه حديث عن بخموت التي
اصبحت باجنر لاند
القتال ضار في شوارع باخمت التي ينسبها
بريكوجين لشركته وتحديدا في الشق الغربي
المتبقي من المدينه ليس في ضخمه وحدها
تدور الحرب في جبهات عده تقول روسيا ان
الاوكرانيين عززوا تحصيناتهم وتنشر صورا
لمراقبتهم واستهدافهم بمسيره تابعه لها
وتقول هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدت 50 هجوما روسيا على باخمت ومارينكا
وقالت بالمقابل انها اسقطت 9 مسيرات وشنت
10 غارات على مواقع روسيه وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في زابوريا جنوبا ان روسيا
اكثر من 100 هجوم خلال الساعات الماضيه
بقذائف مدفعيه ومسيرات وصواريخ جراد تشارك
زابوريا بدورها في احد التطورات اللافته
الاخرى في يوميات الحرب مع ما يتحدث عنه
مسؤولون اوكرانيون من اخلاء تنفذه القوات
الروسيه والموالون لها لبلدات ومناطق فيها
وفي خرس اللتين تعتبران اوكرانيا اراضيا
محتله تترقب روسيا الهجوم الربيعيه
المضاده عليها
كل الاخبار الوارده من الاراضي المحتله
مؤقتا فيزا مرتبطه بطريقه او باخرى
بالهجوم المضاد وذعر القوات الروسيه
والمتعاونين معها من ذلك المحتلون يواصلون
اخلاء مستوطنات عده في زبالوجيا ومناطق
اخرى دون الاعلان عن ذلك في الحرب ايضا
سجال صاروخي اخذ منحا لافتا يعلن رئيس
جمهوريه القرم الموالي لروسيا سيرجي
اكسيونوف ان الدفاع الجوي الروسي اسقط
صاروخا بالستيا اوكرانيا فوق شبه الجزيره
دون ضحايا او اضرار وفي المقابل توظف
اوكرانيا للمره الاولى منظومه باتريوت
الدفاع الجوي وتعلن اسقاط الصاروخ روسي من
طراز كينجال فرط الصوتي في كييف الخميس في
تطور يلفت الانتباه الروسي
لتاثير الامدادات الغربيه على مسار الحرب
بالعوده الى صاروخ كنجار الذي اسقطته
اوكرانيا هذا الصاروخ الروسي يعتبر من اهم
الصواريخ في الترسانه الروسيه ومن احداثها
نتعرف على اهم صفاته في هذا العرض
تستخدم روسيا في هجومها على اوكرانيا جزءا
من جيلها الجديد من الصواريخ التي تعتبرها
موسكو لا تقهر صاروخ كنجال البالستي او
الخنجر باللغه الروسيه احد صواريخ الجيل
الجديد من الاسلحه وهو قادر على الطيران
بعشره اضعاف سرعه الصوت يعتبر هذا الصاروخ
من احدث الاسلحه التي طورتها روسيا ضمن
الصواريخ الباليسيه التي تطلق من الجو
تقول موسكو ان هذا الطراز من الصواريخ
يمكن التحكم به بشكل كبير وتعجز عن رصده
كل انظمه الدفاع الجوي تبلغ سرعه هذا
الصاروخ نحو 12 الف كيلو متر في الساعه
وهو قادر على تدمير الاهداف بمدن يصل الى
2000 كيلو متر ويمكن تسليحه براس حربي
نووي الصاروخ مصمم ليطلق من على متن
طائرات مقاتله منها ميغ واحد وثلا ثون
وقاذفات توبوليف اسناني وعشرون ويبلغ وزن
راسه الحربي 500 كيلو جرام كما انه مخصص
لتدمير الاهداف المهمه للعدو وكذلك
استهداف السفن الحربيه وحتى حاملات
الطائرات
من عمان اللواء فايز الدوير الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجيه وابدا من هذا التطور لكن
لدينا التطورات اخرى فايز تحتاج الى
مناقشه ما معنى اسقاط اوكرانيا لهذا
الصاروخ
يعني هذا جاء رد على التصريح الروسي
السابق بانها الصاروخ والصاروخ صارمات
كلاهما لا يمكن اعتراضه والان جاء الخبر
باسقاط احد هذه الصواريخ وهذا امر متوقع
لماذا اسقط بصاروخ باك 3 عندما نعمل
مقارنه رياضيه ما بين الصاروخين نجد ان
صاروخ
الخنجر كانجال
يحتاج الى 27 دقيقه ثانيه
منذ لحظه اكتشافي لوصول الهدف وبينما
صاروخ باكثري يحتاج تسع ثواني من لحظه
اكتشاء الاكتشاف الصاروخ القادم ليتم
اطلاقه اذا هنا نتحدث عن زمنين زمن
الفاعليه لصاروخ الباتريوت يكون متقدما
بحدود حسب سرعه الصاروخ
سبعه الى نعم وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن تطور
في الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني تطور واضح بعد
وصول هذه الص
اروخ
من التصريحات اللافته هو تصريحات
قائد شركه ومقاتله
بالامس ثم تصريحاته اليوم بالامس
ولعان لوزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان بسبب
نقص الذخيره اليوم يطالب رسميا او يقول
انه سيطالب رسميا بتسليم باخ موت من قواته
الى قوات قديروف لماذا قدروف لماذا ليس
الجيش ليس للجيش الروسي
هو في منافسه حاده مع الجيش الروسي وموضوع
الذخيره هي دعني اقول قمه جبل الجليد من
الخلافات ما بين قائد قوات فاجنر والمؤسس
العسكريه ووزاره الدفاع هو اختصرها بصيغه
فقط تبين مدى الحاجه ومدى محاوله تحجيم
الانتصارات التي تقوم بها مجموعه لكن كثير
من التقارير التي صدرت تتحدث عن خلافات
اعمق تتحدث عن مد النفوس داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه
خلافات حول
نظام التخصيص الموازنات
لموازره الحرب او نظام المكافات او ادماج
المقاتلين في نظام التعويضات او تحويل
قوات فاجنر الى جيش شعبي يعني الخلافات
كبيره جدا خاصه انه هو يسعى الى طموح شخصي
وقد
[موسيقى]
سكان مخيم نور الشمس في مدينه طولكرم
بالضفه الغربيه الشابين الفلسطينيين
قتلتهما قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح
اليوم ونعت حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس
الشاهدين اكدت انتمائهما لكتائبها
العسكريه كتائب القسام واكدت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه من الشابين الشاهدين هما حمزه
خريوش وسامر الشافعي واردد المشيعون
شعارات تدعم المقاومه وتندد باجراءات
الاحتلال الامنيه الاستثنائيه التي يتخذها
بحق الفلسطينيين
في مخيم نور شمس في طولكرم ياتي ضمن
اقتحامات عسكريه عديده نفذ الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه منذ مطلعي
هذا العام نتعرف على ابرزها في هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
وفي الضفه الغربيه ايضا قتل مستوطن
اسرائيلي شابا عربيا من بلده سندره في مرج
بني بن عامر داخل الخط الاخضر ليس في
الضفه الغربيه وانا اتحركته حماس الشهيد
ديار العمري الذي ارتقى برصاصي مستوطن في
البلده ووثق شهود عيان خلافا واشتباكا
بالايدي وقع بين الاثنين في شارع اليقود
الى مستوطنه غاننير المقاومه على تلال شرق
قريه صندله داخل الخط الاخضر وقد شوهد
المستوطن وهو يشهر مسدسه ويطلق النار على
الضحيه وذكر الاهالي ان الشاب الضحيه هو
ديار العمري ويبلغ من العمر 19 عاما اعلنت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه انها اعتقلت الجاني
وضبطت السلاح الذي كان بحوزتها
وللحديث عن التصايد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه ينضموا الينا من رام الله الدكتور
هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث
السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
لماذا يعتبر ما حدث اليوم في طولكرم
تصعيدا
ما حدث يعتبر تصعيدا لانه لا ياتي ردا على
عمليه فدائيه فلسطينيه ادت الى وقوع قتلى
اسرائيليين وانما هو مبادره من قوات
الاحتلال لقتل ما تعتقد انهم مقاومين قبل
ان يفكروا او ان ينفذوا عمليات وهذا خشيه
من انتقال يعني ظواهر الكتائب في جنين وفي
نابلس الى طولكرم والى مناطق اخرى لان
انتقالها سيجعل مساله التعامل معها اكثر
صعوبه وسيسبب لاسرائيل خسائر اكبر هذا هو
الذي يفس كمان تحاول اسرائيل ان تعطي
الثقه للمستوطنين الذين وجهوا انتقادات
كبيره للحكومه وللجيش لان ردودهم على
اطلاق الصواريخ الفلسطينيه وعلى العمليات
الفلسطينيه كانت ضعيفه وهذا يمس بقوه
الردع الاسرائيليه وبالتالي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تحاول من خلال هذه العمليات
بالامس في نابلس واليوم في طولكرم وقبل
ذلك في اريحا وفي جنين ان تعطي الثقه
بانها قويه وقادره على القتل وقادر على
كسر اراده الشعب الفلسطيني على المقاومه
منذ مطلع العام وربما قبله اقتحمت جنين
ونابلس قد تكون شبه يوميه ما خصوصيه
طولكرم
اعتقد ان خصوصيه طولكرم ان هي قريبه جدا
من المنطقه التي اقيمت عليها اسرائيل
مثلما يقال هي على مرمى حجر وبالتالي اذا
امتدت يعني كتائب المقاومه وتغلغلت في هذه
المنطقه سيكون لها قدره كبيره على تنفيذ
اعمال داخل الخط الاخضر وهذا ما تخشاه
يعني اسرائيل اما لماذا هذه الاقتحامات
وتاخذ شكل
الكر والفر وعدم البقاء في المناطق
ومحاوله لتصفيه البنيه التحتيه للمقاومه
ضمن عمليه تسمى عمليه الصور الواقي كما
حدث في عام 2002 عدم الاقدام على هذه
العمليات يعود الى اولا هناك خلافات داخل
يعني الحكومه من جهه وما بين الاجهزه
الامنيه حول مدى الحاجه الى عمليات يعني
بقاء دائمه في المناطق الفلسطينيه التي
تشكل تهديدا لان هذا البقاء يمكن ان يؤدي
الى خسائر في صفوف القوات الاسرائيليه
لا يمكن ان لا يؤدي الغرض بمعنى ان لن
يستطيع القضاء على المقاومه بشكل نهائي
وبالتالي يحاول ان يحققوا الغرض من خلال
اعمال متكرره واحيانا بشكل يومي واختيال
واعتقال المطلوبين والانسحاب يعني بعد
ساعات قليله هذا هو التكتيك الذي تعتمده
القوات الاسرائيليه حتى الان ومع ذلك هناك
ضغوط يعني زي ما قلت داخل الحكومه وداخل
بعض الاجهزه الامنيه
باستخدام قوه اكبر واحتلال مناطق لفتره
طويله ومحاوله لتصفيه البنيه التحتيه
للمقاومه بشكل كبير ولكن هذا جرب سابقا
ولم ينفع الا لفتره مؤقته حيث عادت يعني
المقاومه بشكل اكبر وباشكال جديده وفيما
عرف المقاومه الفرديه وتنتقل من منطقه الى
منطقه وبالتالي مع زخم شعبي يعني كبير
نلاحظه من خلال عده مؤشرات بما في ذلك
الجنازات للشهداء التي يشارك فيها عشرات
الالاف شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله الدكتور
هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث
السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا وفيها توج الملك تشارلز
الثالث وقرينته الملكه كماله في احتفال
المهيب اقيم في كاتدرائيه واسمان في لندن
وحضر الاحتفال عدد من زعماء العالم عدد
كبير من الزعماء وتوافرت جماهير غفيره الى
لندن لمشاهده الاحتفال وسط اجراءات امن
مشدده وايضا اجراءات جديده خاصه بالتظاهر
شارك في هذه الاجراءات الاف من رجال الامن
انه يوم التتويج يوم مشهود في تاريخ
بريطانيا وملكها من ابرز ملامح اليوم وضع
التاج على راس الملك والملكه واجلاسهما
على العرش بعد ان يقدم الملك عهده لشعبه
ويتلقى عهود الولاء من الراعيه وولي العهد
التتويج طقس رئيسي من طقوس يحرص النظام
الملكي البريطاني عليها ومظهر من مظاهر
الابهه والعظمه تعيد من خلاله العائله
الملكيه تجديد صورتها واظهار وحدتها
من قصر باركينجام الى كاتدرائيه ويست
مونستر سار موكب الملك تشارلز الثالث
ذهابا وايابا على خطى عشرات من اسلافه
الذين حكموا هذه البلاد قرابه الف عام
تمت انتقادات استهدفت الحكومه لعدم
اعلانها كلفه الاحتفال التي قدرت باكثر من
مئه مليون جنيه استرليني ولعدم الغاء
الاحتفال الذي اسقطته كل ملكيات اوروبا
منذ قرن في وقت تعتصر فيه المواطن
البريطانيه ازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه امر يراه
البعض غير مبرر بالنظر الى عائدات تدرها
العائله الملكيه على البلاد اقلها من
السياحه
كلفه حفل التتويج ليست كبيره بينما
العوائد تفوقها بكثير
انتهى يوم التتويج اذا بعد ان شكل تدشينا
لعصر جديد عصر انتظره تشارلز الثالث 70
عاما هي مده حكم امه الراحله اسد الله
الصاوي الجزيره لندن
وانه ليلا من
بلاك المؤرخ البريطاني والكاتب في شؤون
الملكيه دكتور جيرمي ما المختلف في تتويج
اليوم
للملك الاربعين لعرش البريطاني عن تتويج
امه قبل سبعين عاما
حين تم تتويج الملكه الراحله اليزابيث كان
لبريطانيا الامبراطوريه الكبرى في العالم
وبالتالي العالم باسره عنا له هذا التدفيش
في عامنا هذا فان بريطانيا صارت قوه اصغر
حجما واقل قوه ويبقى التتويج فعاليه مهمه
للبريطانيين ولمن يعتبرون الملكه حاكمهم
ولكنه اقل اهميه بالنسبه الى العالم باسره
في التقرير الذي استمعنا اليه قبل قليل
سيده من الذين حضروا قالت جمله اريد لك
اريدك ان تشرحها لنا قالت لن يحكمنا
ديكتاتور
طالما لدينا ملك الي مدى تؤيد هذه الجمله
حق القول انه اذا كان
من المحقق القول انه اذا كان لدينا ملك
فهذا يعني انه سوف لن يكون لدينا ديكتاتور
ما نشهده مع هذه الملكيه هو شعور او حس
بالاستمراريه وهذا امر نلمسه ايضا في
الملكيات في دول الخليج التناقض واضح اذا
قررنا ذلك مثلا بروسيا او بدول اخرى من
العالم حيث ان الحاكم هناك ليس هناك قيود
لتصرفاتها هذا يعني ان هذا يخلق مشاكل
اضافيه ايضا الملكيه في بريطانيا الى اي
مدى يعني لا زالت لها شعبيتها
خصوصا ان الملكه اليزابيث تكون ملكه محل
اجماع في معظم اوقات حكمها هذا عكس الملك
شارلز الذي له مواقف مختلفه اختلف عليها
البريطانيه
اقصد انه من الواضح ان الملكيه محبوبه او
شائعه ولكن الامر يختلف بالنسبه الى كل
ملك على حده من حيث شعبيته هناك ملوك في
او هناك داعمون الملكيه في بريطانيا وهناك
ملاحظون لها ومن المحتمل انه خلال
عهد تشارلز قد تستقل استراليا وتصير
جمهوريه ولكن من المنصف القول ان غالبيه
الشعب يريد الحفاظ على الملاكيه
البريطانيه وايضا نظرنا الى ضفتي الاطلسي
واذا راينا المشاكل التي تسبب بها الرئيس
السابق ترامب وانتخابات لعام 2020 المثيره
للجدل فالشعب البريطاني
حين يرى ذلك يختار الا يسير في المسار
نفسه
لكن هذا لم يمنع ان بريطانيا لديها
مشكلاته سواء الخارجيه ومشاركتها في حروب
لانا قتل فيها ولا جمل او مشاكلها
الداخليه يعني هذا الحفل البارخ الذي
رايناه اليوم قد لا ينظر اليه بعيد العطف
من لا يجدون قوته حتى هؤلاء الذين يقفون
في طوابير امام بنوك الطعام
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على شعبيه
الملك تشارلز مع اصراره على ان يكون هذا
الحفل بهذه الصوره
انه في كل فعاليه تتويج هناك ما يثير
الجادل هذا ليس بجديد ولكنكم محقون تماما
انتم محقون حين تقولون
انه لا يمكن ان يكون الجميع راضيا وانه
هناك تحرك
باتجاه
جمهوريه ولكن ايضا اذا اجرينا استفتاء حول
ما اذا يجب ان نبقى ونبقي على الملكيه او
ننتقل الجمهوريه في الوقت الحالي ان نتائج
ستكون داعمه لاستمراريه الملكيه والحكم
الملكي لا يسعني ان احسم ما قد يحصل بعد
100 عام وربما
بعد 50 عاما ولكن حاليا هذا هو الوضع ونحن
منصفون حين نقول ذلك ان
الاحزاب السياسيه
لا سواء الحزب المحافظ او حسب المحافظين
او حسب العمال
كل هذه الاحزاب لا تدعم الجمهوريه
وبالتالي من غير المرجح ننتقل الى
الجمهوريه من جهه اخرى فان الحركه
الانفصاليه في ايرلندا الشماليه تريد
حقبه الجمهوريه تريد ان تنضم الجمهوريه
ايرلندا وهناك دعم في الحزب السكوت لاندي
القومي حيث هناك بعض القاده فيها الذين لا
يريدون استمراريه الملكيه لكن بالنسبه الى
غالبيه الاحزاب السياسيه في
لا تريد الانتقال الى الجمهوريه
البريطاني والكتف في شؤون الملكيه ضيفنا
من
[موسيقى]
اخبارنا الاخرى كد رئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شاع السوداني على ضروره حصول بلاده
على حصتها من المياه كامله وغير منقوصه
عبر الطرق الدبلوماسيه وعبر التواصل مع
دول الجوار دون تصعيد على حد تعبير وقال
السوداني في كلمه له خلال مؤتمر بغداد
الدولي الثالث للمياه الذي عقد في العاصمه
العراقيه
انقاذ نهري دجله والفرات من مخاطر الجفاف
يستدعي تدخلا دوليا عاجلا
كانت لقاءاتنا مع المسؤولين في الدول التي
نتشارك معها في المياه تتركز على ضروره ان
يحصل العراق على حصته كامله غير منقوس
فضلا عن العمل على تكثيف الجهود الفنيه
عبرا لجان المشترك
للاسهام في حل الاشكالات مع هذه الدول
وعبر الطرق الدبلوماسيه والتعاون المشترك
بعيدا عن لغه التصعيد ان انقاذ دجله
والفرات يستدعي تدخلا دوليا عاجلا
انتقد منه مجلس الامن القوميه الايرانيه
علي الشمخاني تصريحات مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكسا التي قال فيها ان واشنطن
ستدعم اي قرار اسرائيلي ضد ايران اذا ما
اقدمت على صنع قنبله نوويه وقال شمخني في
تغريده ان هذا الموقف يعني اعترافا من
واشنطن بماس الاسرائيليه على الاشخاص
والمنشات النوويه في ايران مضيفا ان على
واشنطن ان تتحمل تبعت ذلك
قال الرئيس الايرانيه ابراهيم رئيسي
النيران والسعوديه دوله ثانيه كبيرتان وان
الاتفاق الاخيره بينهما سيغير المعادلات
في المنطقه واضاف رئيسيه ان طهران لن
تقبلها بان تصنف الرياضه عدوه لها او ان
تنظر السعوديه لايران كعدوه واكد ان العدو
الاساسيه هو الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
واوضح ان السياسه ما سماها
الايرانوفوبيا تروج لها واشنطن وتل ابيب
بهدف ضرب الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
شارك الباكستانيين في مسيرات بمدن عده
لدعم قرار المحكمه العليا اجراء
الانتخابات في اقليم البونجاب في الرابع
عشر من مايو ايار الجاري والذي رفضته
الحكومه الباكستانيه اشارك في المسيره في
مدينه لاهورا عاصمه البونجاب عمران خان
زعيم وحزب انصاف المعارض وقال خان في كلمه
ان الحكومه تسعى الى اتخاذ خطوات متعمده
لتدمير الدستور والمحكمه العليا وان
الانتخابات هي الحل الوحيد لاخراج البلاد
من هذه الازمه وفق تعبيره
قتل خمسه واربعه وخمسون شخصا في الهند
جراء اشتباكاته العرقيه في ولايه ماري
بورش شمال شرقي البلاد وقد ارسلت السلطات
تعزيزات الامنيه لاعاده النظام الى
الولايه بعد ان تحولت مسيره احتجاجيه
لمجموعات قبريه الى اعمال عنف وتحتاج
مجموعات خبريه على مطالب مجموعه ماتي التي
تمثل الاغلبيه في ولايه باعتراف الحكومه
بها ضمن فئه ما يسمى القبيله المجدوله
ويمنح القانون الهندي القبائل المندرجه في
تصنيف القبيله المجدوله حصصا في الوظائف
الحكوميه وفي القبول بالجامعات كاحدى
انواع المبادرات التي تسعى لمعالجه
التمييز وعدم المساواه لكن مجموعات قبليه
معترفه بها ترفض منح مجموعه ميسي هذا
التصنيف
نقل مرسل الجزيره في افغانستان عن مسؤول
الحكومي قوله ان خمسه اشخاص قتلوا واصيب
25 جراء فيضانات اجتاحت اربع مديريات في
ولايه الشرقيه البلاد وقال المسؤولين
الفيضانات ادت الى تدمير اكثر من 300 منزل
في مناطق متفرقه من الولايه وان السلطات
المحليه تطالبت بمساعدات عاجله من الحكومه
الافغانيه والمؤسسات الدوليه
مستمرون معكم في جوله الحصاد وهذا تذكير
باهم العناوين
لاول مره منذ بدء الازمه محادثات في مدينه
جده السعوديه بين الطرف النزاع في السودان
ومتحدث باسم الجيش يقول للجزيره ان
المناقشات تركز على الهدنه ولن تبحث
اتفاقا نهائيا لوقف اطلاق النار ميدانيا
معارك ضاريه حول مواقع استراتيجيه ومقر
عسكريه بالخرطوم
بعد انتقادات لرئاسه الاركان الروسيه بسبب
ما اعتبره نقصا في الذخيره رئيس فاجنر
يطلب من موسكو تسليم مواقع مجموعته في
باخموت لقوات قاديروفاريه اوكرانيا تقول
ان منظومه الامريكيه اسقطت صاروخ الروسيا
فرط صوتي
تقول انها اسقطت صاروخير باريس اوكرانيين
فوق شبه جزيره القرم
في تصعيد جديد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يغتال
شابين فلسطينيين في طولكرم بالضفه الغربيه
الشاهدين وتؤكد انتمائهما لكتائب القسام
وفصائل فلسطينيه تدعو الى التصعيد
وفي احتفال يمزج بين التاريخ والحداثه
تتويج تشارلز الثالث على عرش المملكه
المتحده في اكبر حدث من نوعه في بريطانيا
منذ سبعه عقود بحضور قاده وشخصيات من
انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في الساعه الثانيه من الحصاد
نبداها بالتطورات الميدانيه في السودان
اكد طرف النزاع هناك
مشاركتهما في محادثات تعقد في مدينه جده
السعوديه هي الاولى منذ اندلاع الازمه
السودانيه ورحبت الرياضه واشنطن بهذه
المحادثات الاوليه واعربتها عن الامل في
ان تؤدي لانهاء النزاع بينما قال متحدث
باسم الجيش السوداني للجزيره ان التفاوض
يبحث اليات تمديد الهدنه ولا يشمل القضايا
السياسيه
هي اللغه ذاتها
كالا صدى هنا لاحاديث السلام بين اشتباكات
وقصف وانفجارات توزعت ساعات يوم جديد من
عمر محنه السودان تلك يوميات السودانيين
الموعودين بواحده اخرى من هدن المتحاربين
الهشه
تتوقع دوائر استخباراتيه غربيه معارك
طويله الامد في السودان لان الطرفين كما
تقول يعتقدان ان بامكان كل منهما الانتصار
عسكريا وانه ليست لديهما دوافع تذكر
للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
نحو ذلك التفاوض تدفع جهود مجموعه دول
الرباعيه وجامعه الدول العربيه والاليه
الثلاثيه لذلك فهي تبارك الحراك الامريكيه
السعودي الذي اثمر قبلا عن هدن تبادل
المتحاربون في السودان الاتهامات بخرقها
والان تنبثق عن تنسيق الرياض واشنطن
محادثات اوليه هي الاولى من نوعها تجمع
ممثلي كل من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
يقول وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان بلاده تامل ان يقود حوار
الطرفين الى انهاء الصراع وانطلاق العمليه
السياسيه في السودان
ويضيف الوزير السعودي ان استضافه
المباحثات السودانيه هي نتاج تكاتف دولي
وجهود حديثه مع الولايات المتحده وبشراكه
مع دول المجموعه الرباعيه والاليه
الثلاثيه
البيان السعودي الامريكي المشترك بشان بدء
المحادثات السودانيه كان قد حث الطرفين
على الاخذ في الاعتبار مصالح الامه
السودانيه وشعبها والمشاركه بنشاط في
المحادثات نحو وقف اطلاق النار وانهاء
الصراع كما دعا الى مواصله تنسيق الدعم
الدولي لعمليه التفاوض الموسعه والتي قال
انه يجب ان تشمل جميع الاحزاب السودانيه
والى ضروره ضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
قوات الدعم السريع رحبت بالبيان واكد
قائدها محمد حمدان حميدتي في تغريده على
تويتر ما قال انه موقفه الثابت بضروره
الوصول الى حكومه الانتقاليه مدنيه تؤسس
لتحول ديمقراطي كما اشاد حميدتي بالجهود
الاقليميه والدوليه المبذوله للوصول الى
وقف اطلاق نار يسهل فتح ممرات انسانيه
يتفاعل الجيش السوداني هو الاخر بايجابيه
مع محادثات جده لكن ناطقا باسمه قال
للجزيره ان تفاوض سيشمل قضايا عسكريه
وانسانيه ولا علاقه له باي قضايا سياسيه
نحن اعلنا عند انطلاق وفدنا او مغادره
وفدنا الى جده ان هذا الوقت ذهب
وسيناقش الجوارب التي تتعلق بالهدنه بما
يتم تنفيذها لتحقيق او لخدمه الاغراض
الانسانيه بالمقام الاول وان يكن فالقوه
المدنيه الواقعه على الاتفاق الاطاري في
السودان تامل في ان تقود المباحثات الى
وقف القتال ومعالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه بما
يمهد لحل سلمي سياسي مستدام بيان تلك
القوه حث القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
على اتخاذ ما دعاها قرارات شجاعه تنتصر
لصوت الحكمه
مستشار المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
البيت الابيض هذه اول
محادثات سواء كانت مباشره او غير مباشره
بين الطرفين منذ اندلاع هذه الاشتباكات هل
هذا يؤشر على ان هذه المحادثات لها ما
بعدها
نحن لا نعلم بعد فما هو واضح هو انهم
يسيرون شيئا فشيئا بدون خطه واضحه ولا
استراتيجيه واضحه حول شكل هذه
المحادثات كيف ستتطور ربما كلهم يشعرون
بانهم فعلا محظوظين لان الاطراف او
الطرفين قرارات ارسال مبعوثين وبالتالي
لا اعتقد انه كان هناك تخطيط مسبق لو حصل
لا راينا ممثلين عن المجتمع المدني في هذه
المباحثات وهذا ما لم يحصل اخشى ان هذه
المحادثات سوف تعيد ارتكاب اخطاء الماضي
وعدم التقاء الدروس منها بل اعاده
ارتكابها بطريقه
تؤدي الى رفض الشعب السوداني لهواه هنا
الخوف الاكبر
لكن هنالك بيان سعودي
امريكي يرحب بهذه المحادثات وهنالك ايضا
ترحيب من الاطراف في السودان ببيان
الترحيب الامريكي السعودي
الترحيب هنا بماذا تحديدا
يرحبون بان اطراف وافقت على البدء بهذه
المحادثات ولكننا سمعنا الكثير من هذه
التصريحات التي رحبت بوقف لاطلاق النار لم
يكن موجود موجودا في الواقع يجب ان نخشى
ان هذه المحادثات قد لا تكون حقيقيه او
فعليه لم يسبقها اي استعدادات
لم تواجه دعوات الى اطراف خارجيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده كانت في قلبي المحادثات
حول اصلاح القطاع الامير قبل ان تبدا
اعمال العنف ما نفعله واعاده خلق ما حصل
قبل عمل العنف حيث ان انه لدينا الطرفان
المتقاتلين لا اعرف لماذا نتعامل مع نفس
مجموعه الاشخاص ونتحدث عن نفس الامور وكيف
يمكننا ان نتوقع نتائج مغايره بعد ان بدات
المواجهات اعتقد ان الطرفين سيستمراراني
في المواجهات الميدان وسوف يدعيان بانهما
يشاركان في محادثات للاجابه بانهما
يتعاونان مع الاسره الدوليه ولكن في
الحقيقه هذا فرصه لهما الاستمراري في
حربهما ولا يسعنا نتوقع نتائجه
مغايره ما حصل قبل ان يبدا القتال
لا تحبذ المقاربه الامريكيه الحاليه في
الازمه السودانيه ما هي المقاربه المثلى
من وجهه نظرك خصوصا ان الاداره الحاليه
بالفعل اتخذت العقوبات سبيلا لردع الذين
يعرقرون الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان
لنكون واضحين
ان اداره بايدن لم تفرض اي عقوبات هي
اعلانات عن هيئه خاصه العقوبات ولكن لم
تفرض اي عقوبات ليس هناك اي عقوبات مفروضه
على احد
في ازمه السودان
مع انا هذا ما كان يجب ان يحصل بالنسبه
الى هذه المحادثات لماذا ليس لدينا مبعوث
خاص
رفيع المستوى جديد في العلوم المتحده يقود
هذه المباحثات لدينا نفس الامريكيين
والسعوديين يتحدثون عن نفس القضايا مع نفس
الطرفين ويتوقعون
نحن لم نرتقي بهذه المباحث الاهميه الامين
العامل والمتحده لم يحدد مبعوثا خاصا وهذا
لا يحصل على مستوى وزراء خارجيه تتحدث هنا
عن دبلوماسيين
المستوى من الولايات المتحده يشاركون في
ذلك حتى ليسوا مسؤولين رفيعه المستوى على
مستوى
مستشار المبعوث الامريكيه السابق الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
البيت الابيض
وفي التطورات الميدانيه دخلت المواجهات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها
الرابع ففي العاصمه حلقه الطائرات الحربيه
في اجزاء واسعه من وسط الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري كما دوت انفجارات عنيفه في محيط
القصر الرئاسي وحي الوابورات بالخرطوم
وسمعت اصواتها اسلحه ثقيله صباح اليوم
تزامنا مع تصاعدي اعمله الدخان في مواقع
مختلفه جنوب الخرطوم بحري في جنوب مدينه
الاوبيض ادت الاشتباكات بين قوه عسكريه
تابعه لدعم السريع واحدى المكونات
الاجتماعيه الى مقتل ثمانيه اشخاص وجرح
اخرين واشارت مصادر للجزيره ان اسباب
الاقتتال ذات طابع قبلي اخيرا قدرت نقابه
الاطباء السودانيه عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات
المدنيين ب 479 قتيلا واكثر من
2500 مصاب
رين من جنوب الخرطوم مره اخرى مراسل
الجزيره الطاهر المرضي كانت الساعه
الماضيه ساعه هادئه
انكسر هذا الهدوء اي شيء
لا نعم حتى الان ليس هنالك ما يكسر هذا
الهدوء هنالك هدوء في جنوب الخرطوم لا
نسمع اصوات لاي نوع من الاشتباكات او
الانفجارات او حتى تحليق للطيران في هذه
اللحظات وهذه الهدنه التي كانت قد يعني
كانت هشه في الصباح الان الامر مختلف
تماما فقط هنالك حاله ترقب لما يدور في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذه
المحادثات هنالك حاله ترقب ايضا
بان تنجح هذه المباحثات وان تكون الهدنه
متماسكه حتى الوصول الى اتفاق ينهي هذه
الحرب لان الاوضاع الانسانيه الان بعد
تتطلب كل الجهد حتى تنتهي هذه الازمه لان
الاوضاع بعد دخول هذه الحرب في اسبوعها
الرابع اصبحت الان الامور اكثر تفاقما من
الناحيه الانسانيه سواء كان من حيث المواد
الغذائيه بالنسبه للاسعار ندره
المواد الغذائيه عدم وجود مصادر امداد
للمحاله التجاريه معظمه المراك التي
المراكز التجاريه الكبيره هي مغلقه فقط
يعتمد المواطن على ما هو موجود داخل هذه
الاحياء ولذلك هنالك التخوف من المواطنين
ان الامور يعني تسير في تفاقمي اذا لم يكن
هنالك حل جذري في مثل هذه الظروف بالاضافه
الى الاوضاع الصحيه ومحاوله ايضا
المواطنين التلمس الطريق الى بعض
المستشفيات ولكنهم يفاجئون بان الكثير من
هذه المستشفيات يعني خرجت عن الخدمه
وبالتالي هم يحاولون التعامل مع الصيدليه
مباشره والارشادات الطبيه ولكن الصيدليات
نفسها الان تعاني من الامداد وكانت هنالك
انقطاع للتيار الكهربائي على كل كل الان
ينتظر حل نهائي لهذه الازمه من خلال
المفاوضات التي بدات في جده شكرا جزيلا لك
طاهر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم
والى مطار بورت سودان الدوليه وصل الطائره
جديده تحمل شحنه جديده من المساعدات
الانسانيه التي تقدمها هيئات وجمعيات
خيريه قطريه وقال محمد صلاح مدير قطاع
الاغاثه والتنميه الدوليه بالهلال الاحمر
القطري ان المساعدات التي وصلت الى مطار
بورتسودان اليوم تقدر بنحو 22 طنا من
المواد الطبيه والاحتياجات الخاصه
بالاسعافات الاوليه سيتم توزيعها على
المتضررين من القتال في السودان
وكانت اولى المساعدات القطريه انطلقت
الليله الماضيه باتجاه مطار بورت سودان
وذلك ضمن خطه المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله
لمتضرري النزاع المسلح القائمه في السودان
كما اجلت القوات المسلحه القطريه 184 شخصا
من المقيمين في الدوحه ومما التقطعت بهم
السبل العوده اليها
من قاعده الاعداد الجويه في الدوحه انطلقت
الرحله الاولى التابعه للقوات الجويه
الاميريه القطريه لنقل المساعدات القطريه
الى مطار بورت سودان وعلى متنها مواد
غذائيه هذا
الدور في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني ليس غريب على قطر نحن تعودنا في
كل الازمات السابقه التي مر بها السودان
وخصوصا في اقليم دارفور كانت قطر في
المقدمه سباقه دائما
بتقديم يد العون والمساعده كل محتاج اليها
شعب السودان
المؤسسات الخيريه القطريه ممثله بقطر
الخيريه والهلال الاحمر القطري وصندوق قطر
للتنميه بادرت الى الاستجابه العاجله
لتقديم مساعدات الانسانيه في المناطق
المتضرره من النزاع المسلح الذي تشهده
مناطق متفرقه في السودان في انطلاق اول
رحله اغاثيه انسانيه جمهوريه السودان
تقديم المساعدات القطريه بالتعاون
والتنسيق مع صندوق قطر التنميه واللي
نستهدف فيها اخواننا اللي نجحوا من
المناطق الصراع في الخرطوم والمناطق
الاخرى باذن الله راح يتم تسليمها في
بورسودان وبالتنسيق مع الجهات الحكوميه
راح يتم نقل وتوزيع هذه المساعدات للاخوه
المتضررين والنازحين في المناطق اللي هي
الامنه 60 طنا من المواد الغذائيه هي كميه
هذه المساعدات المتجهه الى ميناء
اورتسودان على البحر الاحمر هناك سيتم
انزالها واجلاء مواطنين سودانيين وفق خطه
المساعدات الانسانيه القطريه العاجله
تقوم المؤسسات الخيريه القطريه بالتنسيق
مع عدد من المؤسسات والمنظمات الدوليه
بوضع ترتيبات لتوفير المساعدات الانسانيه
العاجله في عدد من المناطق المتضرره لقطر
الخيريه حضور في الميدان لتقديم الامدادات
الغذائيه والطبيه فيما يقوم الهلال الاحمر
القطري بوضع الترتيبات اللازمه لتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله الطائره
القطريه اجلت كذلك عددا من السودانيين
المقيمين في قطر والذين تجاوز عددهم 184
شخصا من فئات عمريه مختلفه
غير ايام الهدن الوضع بيستقر شويه فالواحد
بيقدر يطلع فاخذنا القرار كان قرار صعب
وانه الواحد يطلع من البيت في ظل الحرب
وفي ظل الضرب واصوات الرصاص لمن وصلنا
مدينه بورسودان
سمعنا بمبادره السيد السفير والحمد لله
الان يتم عمليه الاجابه بنجاح ومن المقرر
ان تسيروا قوات الجويه الاميريه القطريه
رحلات اخرى لنقل المساعدات ومنها مستشفى
الميداني ومواد طبيه وادويه احمد الجاسم
الجزيره من قاعده الاعداد الجويه الدوحه
طلب قائد منطقه البحر الاحمر العسكريه
اللي هو محمد عثمان محمد حمد ممثله الامم
المتحده لدعم الانتقالي في السودان
فولكربرتز بايجاد حل عاجل لازمه الاف
السوريين واليمنيين للعالقين في مدينه
بورسودان واضاف عثمان في مؤتمر صحفي له ان
تدفق الاجانب على المدينه يشكل هاجسا
امنيا كبيرا للجيش السوداني
نحن ما نرجو انه السيد مبعوث الامم
المتحده المتواجده الان في بورسودان انه
يعمل على حل مشكله السوريين يا اما او
اليمنيين بالاخص السوريين اليمنيين يا اما
اجلاهم الى الى الى بلادهم يا اما اجلاهم
الى اي بلد اخر يا اما
يعملون في معسكرات مع للاجئين يكون خارج
الولايه وهذا ما نزع اليوم حتى انه ما
يكون يعني العدد الكثير من التواجد
الاجنبي يمكن يكونوا بشكل لنا هاجس او
تحديات الامنيه
وتنضم الينا من نيويورك
كورتوال مراقبه دائما للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر لدى الامم المتحده ونبدا
بتصريح قائد البحر الاحمر السوداني هنالك
الاف كما يقول او على الاقل اعداد كبيره
من السوريين واليمنيين العالقين في
بورسودان ما الذي ينبغي ان يحدث مع هؤلاء
لا سيما ان كثيرا من الموجودين في
بورتسيدان الان ربما لا توجد اماكن امنه
او ليس من الامان ان يعودوا الى اوطانهم
سواء كانوا مطاردين منها او كانت في وقت
عدم عدم استقرار كاليمن وسوريا او ما شابه
ذلك
بالنسبه الى الوضع فهو معقد كثيرا لسيما
لمن طلبوا اللجوء في السودان قبل اعمال
العنف نعرف ان السودان فيها اكثر من مليون
لاجئ ونعرف ان البعض منهم يعودون الى
دولهم طبعا مع وجود مخاوف بالنسبه الى
قدره استيعاب هذه الدول لهم ولعودتهم
وما يتعلق ايضا
بشؤون حمايتهم طبعا نحن قلقون جدا لقد
ظهرت موجات من التضامن من الدول التي
تستقبل هؤلاء العائدين او لاجئين من دول
اخرى ونتمنى ان نستمر ذلك مع العمل مع
الوكالات والهيئات المسؤوله التي توري
اهتماما خاصا للاجئين لكن كل عمليات
الاجلاء من بورتسودان لم تشمل اللاجئين
شملت اصحاب الجنسيات الاجنبيه الذين
يريدون العوده بسهوله الى بلدانهم او
الذين لديهم اقامات في دول اخرى لكن من
ليس لديه لا اقامه في دوله ولا جنسيه دوله
يمكن ان يعود اليها بامان كيف يتم التعامل
معه
الدوليه لصليب الاحمر ليست بالضروره
مسؤوله عن هؤلاء العائدين ولكن لدينا برغم
من ذلك فرق موجوده عند المعابر من اجل
تسهيل العوده اولا من منظور انساني حيث
نحرص على انه يتم الاهتمام بهم حينئائي
يعبرون الحدود لدي مقدره الوصول الى
المياه والغذاء والمساكن وايضا
خدمات خاصه
بالعائلات
لتسهيل لم الشمل او للتواصل مع افراد
الاسره حين يعودون الى جنوب السودان لدينا
فرق عند الحدود لاستقبالهم بالتنسيق مع
وكالات واجهات اخرى تعنى بقضايا محدده
فيما يتعلق بمستنداتهم ووثائق السفر
الملائمه
بشكل عام ما هو تقييمكم
لتعامل الطرفين مع المستشفيات في السودان
لقد عربنا عن مخاوفنا علنا منذ اندلاع
اعمال العنف في الخمس عشر من ابريل فكان
مقرقا جدا ان نرى كيف ان المستشفيات ليست
بالضروره محترمه كما يجب ان يحصل بموجب
القانون الانساني الدولي
وبموجب المبادئ الانسانيه
يتم افراغها او لا يتم امدادها بما هي
بحاجه اليه وتصير على شفير الانهيار ليس
فيها كهرباء ليس لديها مواد ومعدات ولا
قدره الوصول العلمياه
وتعصير عاجزه عن معالجه المرضى
المشكله ايضا تكمن في كثره عدد المرضى
الذين يتوفدون الى المستشفيات حيث ليس
هناك ما يكفي من المواد وامداد المستشفى
عاده كل يومين او ثلاثه بما تحتاجه ولكن
منذ العمل العنف قد انقطعت سلسله التوريد
هذا هو بالتالي حاولنا قدر الامكان ان
نوفر هذه المساعدات العينيه الى البلاد
والى
المستشفيات
بالرغم من صعوبه الوضع وبطئ الامداد ومن
هذا نطلب من الطرفين الحرص على تسهيل
توصيل الامدادات الى المستشفيات التي صارت
قدراتها محدوده لمعالجه المرضى لا سمع
العمل عاجزه عن الوصول الى المستشفى شكرا
جزيلا لك من نيويورك
المراقبه دائما للجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر
[موسيقى]
الان الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا واخر
تطوراتها وفي اخر التطورات افاده مرسل
الجزيره ببدء اعلان حاله التاهب الجويه في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف ومناطق شرق وجنوب
اوكرانيا كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع
انفجارات في دينيبرو وخيرسون التي اعلنت
السلطاتها مقتل سته من موظفي ازاله
الالغام في قصف روسي على المقاطعه بينما
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه اندفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت خمسه مسيرات انتحاريه روسيه
خلال هذا اليوم ومن جانب الاخر اكد المدير
العام لوكاله الطاقه الذريه رافايل جروسسي
البدء باجلاء السكان من مدينه انرجودار
الاوكرانيه حيث توجد محطه
عبر جروسي عن قلقه من تزايد الاعمال
العسكريه في منطقه المحطه التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه واضافها جروسيه ان
موظفي المحطه النوويه وعائلاتهم يعيشون في
ظروف صعبه وان تراقب عن كثب اي تاثير
محتمل على السلامه والامن النوويين
ينضم الينا من كيف مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود حسان في الساعه الماضيه لم تكن
ترتدي هذا الزي الواقي من الرصاص
كان هنالك انذار جوي وتاهب جوي وحديث عن
تحرك للقاذفات الاستراتيجيه الروسيه فما
الذي جرى خلال هذه الساعه
نعم زي النخله هذه الدقائق تم
الاعلان عن سماع ذوي انفجارات في مقاطعه
ميكو لايف عبر الزميل مراسلنا هناك تمر
صمادي اكد هذه المعلومه
في مقاطعه ميكو لايف جنوبا وفي ذات
الاثناء ايضا يجري الحديث عن اطلاقه عدد
من الصواريخ من سبع قاذفات استراتيجيه
تحلق في الاجواء تحديدا فوق البحر الاسود
كان هناك حديث عن قذيفات استراتيجيه رصدت
فوق مقاطعه كريسنو داير جنوب روسيا وهناك
ايضا حديث عن القاذفات استراتيجيه تحلق
فوق شبه جزيره القرم وهذا يعني ان المناطق
التي تخضع للانذار الجوي حاله التاهب
القصوى التي اعلنت منذ ساعتين وحتى هذه
اللحظه وتشمل هنا العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
وعدد من المقاطعات شمال وشرق اوكرانيا
تحت خطر الاستهداف هذه القذفات
الاستراتيجيه زين تحمل صواريخ يمكن ان يصل
مداها الى اكثر من 2000 كيلومتر
وتسير بسرعه الصوت او تفوق سرعه الصوت في
حاله كانت تحمل صواريخ من طراز كنجال التي
كنا قد تحدثنا عن اعلان القوات الجويه
اسقاط احد الصواريخ لاول مره منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب حتى هذه اللحظه يجري الحديث عن
صواريخ من طراز اثنان وعشرون
يتم اطلاقها عبر القاذفات الاستراتيجيه من
سماء مقاطعه ميكرويف بينما اتحدث معك الان
عمده مقاطعه
يدعو المواطنين الى التوجه الى الملاجئ
والاحتماء نظرا لاطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
منطقه الجنوب ولكن بكل الاحوال المنطقه
باكملها من الجنوب وحتى اقصى الشمال من
الشرقيه بالاضافه الى المنطقه الوسطى
وتحديدا هنا
منطقه ايضا كياف تخضع لحاله الانذار الجوي
ومعظم الادارات العسكريه تدعو المواطنين
لاتخاذ اقصى تدابير
والاحتماء وفي ذات الوقت ايضا يجري الحديث
الان عن بدء تفعيل الدفاعات الجويه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه
لاوكرانيا
الطائرات التي تحلق في السماء وهي القذفات
الاستراتيجيه يجري الحديث انها من طراز
توبوليف 22 ام ثلاثه هذا هو نوع الطائرات
التي تحلق في الاجواء والتي تؤدي الى هذا
الانذار الجوي عاده ما تنطلق هذه الطائرات
اما لمهام استطلاعيه لتستطلع مواقع
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه وتقوم بقصف
ايضا هذه المواقع في حال تمكنت من رصدها
او
للقيام بعمليات اطلاق حقيقيه وهو ما جرى
اليوم
قامت هذه القاذفات بالتحليق لاكثر من
ساعتين قبل ان تبدا باطلاق الصواريخ وما
زالت المواقع
والادارات العسكريه المحليه تتحدث عن
استمرار لاطلاق الصواريخ حتى هذه اللحظه
من منطقه البحر الاسود وعن استمرار
الدفاعات الجويه ايضا
بالعمل
لمحاوله اسقاط هذه الصواريخ كانت اوكرانيا
قد تسلمت دفاعات جوي من طراز باتريوت هذه
الانظمه الامريكيه وتحديدا تسلمتها من
المانيا
واستطاعت عبرها اسقاط صاروخ من طراز كنجال
والان سيتم ايضا
متابعه هذه الهجمه الجديده الصاروخيه
لمعرفه ما اذا كانت ستستطيع ستتمكن من
الوصول الى مناطق اخرى غير مقاطعه مي كو
لايف التي تعرضت للقصف قبل قليل اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا حسن مسعود مراسل الجزيره من
كييف
ومن كيف ايضا ينضموا
اليناك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
التصريحات الاوكرانيه وصفت اسقاط صاروخ
كنجال بانه حدث تاريخي لماذا هو حدث
تاريخي
وفعلا حدث تاريخي لانه اولا وكما تعلمون
فان روسيا تقول ان هذه الصواريخ كانجال
لا يمكن
اسقاطها من بالنسبه او من خلال الدفعات
الجويه وقد اثبتنا انه بدفعتنا الجويه
الكافيه يمكن انزالها وبفضل شركائنا الذين
زودون
بمنظومه البيت تمكنا من انزالي هذا
الصاروخ الان هنالك حاله تاهب جوي في
اكياب وفي مدن الجنوب وفي الشرق ما الذي
تخشونه وما الذي يجري في هذه اللحظه
نحن نعيش في جو من الرعب
الصاروخي
لفتره خلال
الايام العشره الاخيره
حصلات اعتداءات وقتل مدنيون اذا نحن نعيش
هذا الرعب منذ فتره وما نركز عليه الان هو
الدفاع او الهجمات المضاده ادركنا
للتخلص من هذه الازمه هو يجب ان ننتصر على
العدو في ميدان المعركه وهذا ما نفعله
فيما يتعلق بجبهات الشرق وبخموت كيف
تنظرون الى ما قاله قائد مجموعه
فاجنر من انه
سببه لوزير الدفاع ولرئيس الاركان وحديثي
عن تسليم المدينه لقوات شيشليه
انا لا اريد ان اتكهن ولا اريد ان احاول
قراءه افكار هؤلاء الارهابيين ما اقوله هو
ان هذه المجموعه الارهابيه فاجنر لم تتمكن
من السيطره على بخ موت وهي مدينه صغيره
منذ ما يقارب تسعه اشهر الان لقد خسروا
عشرات الاف الجنود مهما حصل مهما كانت
النزعه والاتفاقات بين هؤلاء الارهابيين
بالنسبه الينا يجب ان ندرك اننا نزل نسيطر
على بخموت والعدو يتكبد الكثير من الخسائر
وربما اليها هم يائسون ويشعرون بالهلع هو
يقول ان الاوكرانيين لا يسيطرون الا على
كيلو متر او كيلو مترين في بخموت لكن انا
اريد ان اسال ايضا عن هجوم الربيع ما يسمى
بالهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي اطلق عليه
هجوم الربيع تقريبا الربيع قارب على
الانتهاء متى سيكون هذا الهجوم الاوكراني
هل سيكون في الربيع فعلا ام انه تاجل
للصيف
ان وزير الدفاع لدينا قلم منذ ايام ان او
ان الجيش الاوكراني هو مساعد تقريبا
لهذه العمليه المضاده ما يجب ان ندركه هو
ان هذا الهجوم المضاد ليس فعاليه تبدا
بصفاره انطلاق هي مجموعه من العمليات
العسكريه المعقده البعض منها يكون اصغر او
اكبر البعض من هربما قد بدا من خلال مهام
استطلاع من خلال محاوله تابعه نقاط الضعف
لدى العدو طبعا نحن ننتظر المزيد من
الذخائر والاسلحه وكما اسلفت اكد وزيرنا
اننا على استعداد للانطلاق بهذه العمليه
بما يتيح لنا تحرير المزيد من الاراضي
مستشار وزير الدفاع والمتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ضيفنا من كيف شكرا
جزيلا لك
وينضم الينا من موسكو
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه وابدا بهذا التطور الذي قال
الاوكرانيون انه تطور تاريخي اسقاط صاروخ
كنجال الروسي عبر استخدام صواريخ
الامريكيه
الى اي مدى يمثل ذلك تطورا كبيرا
للقدرات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه وفي هذه
الحرب
اعتقد انه حدث كبير
هذا الصاروخ قتم الترويج له على انه علي
السرعه وفي السنوات الاخيره كان هناك
الكثير من الحماس حول هذا النوع من
الصواريخ وانه من المستحيل
رصدها وانزالها ولكن يبدو ان هذا غير صحيح
طبعا هذا الصاروخ تم تطويره على انه نظام
نووي
ان استخدامه في او مع رؤوس حربيه
عاديه او تقليديه كما يحصل في اوكرانيا
هذا ممكن ولكن هذا ليس هدفه الرئيسي ولم
تستخدم الكثير من هذه الصواريخ
ونعم انها فعلا او انه فعلا حدث وهذا سوف
يصير موضوع بحث
دقيق ومفصل من قبل الجيش الروسي والامريكي
والجوش الاوروبي كيف حصل ذلك على هذا كان
حدثا يحصل مره واحده اي تغييرات في
البروتوكولات يجب ان تستتبع ذلك وبالتالي
انه فعلا حدث بارز لاوكرانيا ولحلفائها من
دول الغرب وكيف بما انه حدث بارز
والاوكرانيون وصفوه بانه حدث تاريخي ما
المطلوب او ما الذي تتوقعه من الجانب
الروسي
لتلافي ذلك
هل عدم اطلاق هذه الصواريخ ام تغيير اسلوب
الروس في هذه الحرب
لم يستخدم الكثير من هذه الصواريخ واصلا
لم ينتج عدد كبير منها
الفكره الرئيسيه من هذا الصاروخ
هو ان يكون متوسط الماده
ولكنه لم يخدع
لقيود
معاهده 87 المتحده ومنذ ذلك الحين طبعا
هذه
المعاهده لم تعد مطبقه
ونرى ان الولايات المتحده
تطور هذا النوع من الصواريخ
واعتقد ان روسيا ايضا تعمل على هذه
الصواريخ لانهم
يعتمدون تقنيه اقل
كلفه مقارنه بالميك 31 اذا هذا صواريخ
ليست كثيره من حيث العدد وهي لا تلمع صوره
روسيا ولكنها قد تغير
ميزان هذه المواجهه بين روسيا والغرب
لكن فيما يتعلق بالمواجهه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا هنالك ايضا تطور لافت في جبهه
باخموت التصريحات المتتاليه لرئيس مجموعه
فاجنر وسبابه لوزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
ثم حديثي لاحقا عن الانسحاب وتسليم
المدينه لقوات قادروف وليس لقوات الجيش
كيف تنظر الى هذه التصريحات الاخيره لقائد
مجموعه
[موسيقى]
قدير الشيشه نقال ان قوته مستعده لتطوع
لكي تستبدل او تحل محل قوه
انا لا اعتقد ان هذه فكره سديده بالنسبه
الى شيشان لانه
اذا كانت مجموعه
تجنيد المتطوعين بطريقه مكثفه بما فيهم
مجرمين من السجون الروسيه وكانت مستعده
لتكابد الخسائر الكبيره فان القوات
الشيشانيه ليست مستعده لتكبد هذا العدد من
الخسائر في الارواح
اذا هم اساس نظام
وهو ليس مستعدا لتكبد الخسائر
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه ضيفنا من
موسكو
ولاحقا في فقره المتابعه المتابعه نسلط
الضوء على الدبابات اسقاط صاروخ الصوتي
الروسي بمنظومه باتشوت الامريكيه
سكان مخيم نور الشمس في مدينه طولكرم
بالضفه الغربيه شابين الفلسطينيين قتلتهما
قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم
اخذناها حركه حماس الشهيدين واكلت
انتمائهما لكتائب القسام اكدت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه الى الشابين الشاهدين هما حمزه
خريوش وسامر الشافعي وردد المشيعون شعارات
تدعم مقاومه الاحتلال وتردد باجراءاته
الامنيه الاستثنائيه بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
توج الملك تشارلز الثالث وقرينته الملكه
كامله في حفل المهيب وقيم في كاتدرائيه
وحضر الاحتفال عدد كبير من زعماء العالم
وتوافدت جماهير غفيره الى لندن لمشاهده
الاحتفال وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده شارك
فيها الاف ورجال الامن
انه يوم التتويج يوم مشهود في تاريخ
بريطانيا وملكها من ابرز ملامح اليوم وضع
التاج على راس الملك والملكه واجلاسهما
على العرش بعد ان يقدم الملك عهده لشعبه
ويتلقى عهود الولاء من الراعيه وولي العهد
التتويج طقس رئيسي من طقوس يحرص النظام
الملكي البريطاني عليها ومظهر من مظاهر
الابهه والعظمه تعيد من خلاله العائله
الملكيه تجديد صورتها واظهار وحدتها
من قصر باكين الى كاتدرائيه ويست مونستر
ساره موكب الملك تشارلز الثالث
ذهابا وايابا على خطى عشرات من اسلافه
الذين حكموا هذه البلاد قرابه الف عام
كميه الامطار التي هطلت اليوم على العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن قد تكون الاكثر في يوم
واحد منذ مطلع هذا العام لكن هذا لم يمنع
خروج عشرات الالاف من الجماهير لتقديم
التحيه لملكهم كما لم يمنع خروج اخرين
غيرهم من معارضي الملكيه
اجتمع الفريقان في ميدان ترفالقر وسط لندن
المكان الذي سمحت فيه الشرطه بمظاهره حركه
هناك وقفوا هاتفين ليس ملكي ومنادين
بالتخلي عن الملكيه واعلان بريطانيا
جمهوريه امر اختلف معه اغلب الحاضرين
لتحيه الملك
لن يحكمنا ديكتاتور طالما لدينا ملك
تمت انتقادات استهدفت الحكومه لعدم
اعلانها كلفه الاحتفال التي قدرت باكثر من
100 مليون جنيه استرليني ولعدم الغاء
الاحتفال الذي اسقطته كل ملكيه اوروبا منذ
قرن في وقت تعتصر فيه المواطن البريطانيه
ازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه امر يراه البعض غير
مبرر بالنظر الى عائدات تدرها العائله
الملكيه على البلاد اقلها من السياحه
فيليب سمول
كلفه حفل التتويج ليست كبيره بينما
العوائد تفوقها بكثير
انتهى يوم التتويج اذا بعد ان شكل تدشنا
لعصر جديد عصر انتظره تشارلز الثالث 70
عاما هي مده حكم امه الراحله اسد الله
الصاوي الجزيره لندن
[موسيقى]
تعود لتطورات المداريه في اوكرانيا
وتحديدا اعلان كييف اسقاط صاروخ روسي تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت باربعه اضعاف نتحدث عن
الصاروخ
يعني الخنجر باللغه الروسيه هو احد سته
اسلحه من الجيل القادم كشف عنها الرئيس
الروسي عام 2018
ترافقا مع الاعلان قال بوتين حينها ان
صاروخ انجال كي 47 سلاح مثالي يصعب جدا
على الدفاعات الصاروخيه ان تعترضه انجال
هو الصاروخ البالسي الذي يطلق من الجو
ويمكن ان تصل سرعته الى 12 الفا
وثلاثمائه وخمسين كيلو مترا في الساعه
وقادر على حمل رؤوس حربيه نوويه او
تقليديه وتاشير التقارير لان مداه يتراوح
بين 1500 الى 2000 كيلومتر قائد سلاح الجو
الاوكراني كشف ان الصاروخ الروسي الذي تم
اسقاطه اطلق خلال هجوم روسي على كيف ومدن
اخرى في الساعات الاولى اليوم الخميس
يعني ذلك ان الهجوم جاء بعد اقل من يوم
واحد من اتهام روسيا لاوكرانيا بتنفيذ
محاوله فاشله لاغتيال فلاديمير بوتين
الرئيس الروسي في هجوم بطائره مسيره على
مبنى الكرملين وهدرت بالرده لكن كيف اسقط
كينجا
سلاح الجو الاوكراني يقول ان منظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه هي التي اسقطت
الصاروخ الروسي يعود تصنيع نواه منظومه
الى سته عقود لانها ككثير من انواع
الاسلحه لها طرازات واجيال حديثه ومن
اطراز باك ثري ام اس اي ذو القدرات
العاليه ايضا هو عباره عن نظام صاروخ ارجو
تصنعه شركه
ريثيون الامريكيه ومصمم للحمايه من
الصواريخ المهاجمه والطائرات اذ يقوموا
باسقاطها وتفجيرها في الهواء قبل ان تبلغ
اهدافها هذا الصاروخ له منظومه رادار
تتمكن من رصد 50 هدفا في ان واحد وفي خلال
تسع ثوان فقط يمكنها ان تسقط هذه الاهداف
تسع ثوان من وصول الاشاره الى غرفه التحكم
يمكنها ان تسقط هذه الاهداف في نطاق يمتد
من 60 مترا الى
مترا في السماء انظروا الينا من الاوت
فرانك فرانك كبير الباحثين والخبراء
العسكريين في مؤسسه جلوب ساك
للدراسات صاروخ جال له مواصفات
كبيره الرئيس بوتين كان يقول انه صعب جدا
اسقاطه لكنه سقط
ماذا يعني ذلك للحرب
يعني ان روسيا لم يعد لديها
اداه تضمن لها اصابه الهدف اعتقد ان
كثيرين ومنهم انا
في فتره لم نعد نشكك في في قدره
او نحرش شككنا فيها وقلنا انه احيانا قد
لا تتمكن من انزال
صاروخ الفرد صوتي مثل كينجال ولكنها
انزلته وهذا يعني ان هذا سوف يؤثر كثيرا
على العمليات وعلى القياده العسكريه
الروسيه كيف سيؤثر بالنظر الى ان استخدام
هذه الصواريخ ليس بهذه الكثره في هذه
الحرب
نعم هذا صحيح حيث كان هناك بعض
الاستخدامات السنه الماضيه في ابريل 6 من
هذه صواريخ صواريخ كينجال قد تم اطلاقها
منذ سته اسابيع تقريبا
وبالتالي نحن شبه
اكيدين ان روسيا هي لديها 50 او 60 من
هداء صواريخ باقيه من اجل الضماني عصابه
الاهداف على هدف الصواريخ ان تطلق باكثر
من واحد
وهذا امر مكلف جدا بالنسبه الى روسيا لانه
كما قلت لم يعد بامكانها ان تضمن انها
فعلا سوف تصل الى اهدافها وسوف تخرق دفعات
الاوكرانيه كيف ستعوض يعني اذا كانت قادرا
على اسقاط كنجال
باتروت ربما غير قادر على اسقاط المسيرات
مثلا
كيف ستعوض روسيا عدم الاعتماد على كنجال
في ضرب اهداف كبيره في اوكرانيا ما السلاح
الاخر الذي يمكن ان تستخدمه
الحل المتاح لدى هو ان تطلق الصواريخ
باعداد كبيره اذا كانت تمتلكها يمكن
لمنظومه
ان تصيب المسيرات ودفعه الاوكرانيه
بمعظمها قادر على ذلك ولكن المشكله انها
مكلفه جدا
وبالتالي نحن بحاجه الى ضبط الاستخدام من
اجل نستخدم صواريخ مكلفه جدا لكي نسقط
مسيره روسيه رخيصه الثمن وبالتالي ما يمكن
لروسي ان تقوم به وان تغرق دفاعات الجوله
الاوكرانيه بالكثير من الصواريخ وهذا تحد
كبير امام روسيا اذا هي لم تكن تمتلك عددا
كبيره منها وهل هي تمتلك هذا الكم الكبير
من الصواريخ روسيا تريد ذخيره من كوريا
الشماليه من
حتى من مصر من بلدان اخرى تسعى الى سد
العجز في الذخيره مجموعه تشتكي من الذخيره
الان بعد مرور اكثر من عام وحوالي ثلاثه
اشهر على الحرب ما يكفي من هذه الصواريخ
التي يمكن ان تحسم المعركه
المشكله نفسه تنطبق على اوكرانيا هنا حيث
على عليها ايضا ان تضبط استخدام
الذخائر ولا سيما الان الدفاعات المضاده
للطيران بحسب مجموعه فاكنار فان روسيا
ايضا تعاني نقصا كبيرا
ومعظم المحللين مثلي يقولون انها ايضا قد
استنفذت معظم الصواريخ
موجهه بدقه ولهذا كالجعلان الى صواريخ
كينجا لكي تضمن الدقه والاختراق لدفعه
راويه الاوكرانيه اذا كل من الطرفين يعاني
مشاكل فيما يتعلق بالذخائر المدفعيه وكذلك
الصواريخ
كل منهما يحاول ان يعالج الموضوع ايضا
اوكرانيا تعاني نفس المشكله
وبحسب التسريبات الاخيره بدات تنف ذ
صواريخه الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه ولهذا
يجب ان تضبط استخدامه تسيطر عليه
[موسيقى]
الخبير العسكري في مؤسسه
للدراسه ضيفونه من
[موسيقى]
قد لا يكون هناك ما هو اقصى من ان يخاف
المرء العوده الى وطنه لان هذه هي حال
لاجئيه روهنجيا في بنجلاديش الذي يعيش نحو
مليون منهم في مخيمات بائسه في منطقه كوكس
بازار الحدوديه تمت مشروع برعايه دوليه
هدفه اعادتهم الى ميانمار لكن المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
تقول ان لكل لاجئ الحق الاصيل في العوده
الى وطنه طواعيه لكن لاجئي الروهينجيه
يخشون العوده والعيش في معسكره تحتجاز من
جديد يريدون ضمانات من بينها استعاده
ارضهم والحصول على الجنسيه يقولون لا نريد
شيئا سوى عوده امنه وطوعيه وكريمه
ومستدامه الى الوطن هذا ما نقلته رويترز
عن محمد ميزان الرحمن وهو لاجئ من اقليه
الرهن يعيش في بنغلاديش حال ميزان الرحمن
هو حال الكثيرين الذين يخشون العوده الى
بلدانهم واوطانهم لانهم ليسوا امنين فيها
شكرا على حسن المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]